Her low freak bitches.
It really does bring to mind this incredible verse in the Bhagavad Gita where
Krishna is revealing his true form to our June who's like the warrior figure.
And uh,
this is Oppenheimer's quote,
this is Oppenheimer's quote.
When he did,
he said after the atomic bomb went off,
and I'm a quoted this part of the Bhagavad Gita where he said,
I have become death,
the destroyer of worlds,
but it doesn't stop there.
Krishna's sang to Argentina,
something along the lines of,
look in my teeth there you will see them,
everyone on this battlefield because I'm eating them right now.
So this is like,
this is like Chris,
it'd be like,
oh,
you really want to see what I'm saying?
Cause they've just been friends hanging out and stuff and he like suddenly
became the force of all destruction in the known universe.
And the point of the thing was,
listen,
all of this is already chewed up.
It's already been devoured.
It's already gone.
Game over.
You're done.
No Kurzweil is going to get you new blood cells.
It's going to keep this going to keep you alive at some point.
I will come to you wearing the costume of your death.
And that is an inevitability.
So just surrender to that and you're going to be a lot less freaked out if you
just accept that that's the way it is.
Because if your war that you're engaged in right now is the war to live forever.
If you're a war that you're engaged in right now is a war to try to make some
lasting change in a universe that's defined by impermanence and change,
then you're fighting the wrong war.
There's a better war to fight,
you know,
and it's actually the way you fight it is by surrendering,
not by fighting,
by letting go and sinking into the actual hum of the universe,
the way it really works,
not the way you wish it work,
not the way that you are hoping that the universe worked where uh,
you know,
lions and hyenas rescue little boys like air,
like an ice age,
but the cartoon.
But the way it actually works,
the way the university actually works as everything comes into existence,
it exists for a little while and then it dies
than most things come out of explosions,
eh?
Oh yeah.
Don't forget that.
Yeah.
Most things come out of big fucking blast,
including the whole universe itself.
Yes.
Right.
Whole Universe itself is predicated upon a violent event.
Yeah.
It has to have a violent event.
Right.
That's big bang.
It couldn't be the slow expansion of beautiful life giving particles throughout
the universe now,
nope.
It's a big fucking bang.
No,
it was a big fucking bang and it keeps it,
it keeps going.
The big bank keeps going and is,
but it's just like this,
man.
If you want to dig your heels in and sync your claws into the expanding universe
and try to keep that fucking thing from expanding,
you're going to get ripped apart.
That's just the way it works.
But if you want to let go and merge into the thing,
if you want to allow yourself the fantasy that you're not some individual with a
social security number and a name and parents,
but allow yourself the fantasy that you're 13.8 billion years old and you're
part of this incredible ocean of happening instead of just this one individual,
and just let yourself experience that for a second.
The glorious knowledge that you are a never ending,
ever changing flow of matter that's temporarily manifested with the ability to
express love and do a dimension where things are supposed to be cooling off,
then that's a fun way to spend your time here before you end up getting eaten by
a lion or have a heart attack or whatever happens.
It's just a backflip.
This is uh,
this is like a high dot.
This is like when you see people come off of a high dive and you get like a few
seconds.
It's just some cool fucking tricks.
That's what you get here.
We're like dolphins jumping out of the eternal and we into time and while we
were shoot up into time,
we get a chance to do a couple of back flips,
a couple of Chirps,
and that's our life's work.
And then we plunged back into infinity again.
Do it all over again.
It's like if you're creating characters for fiction and the idea that you can't
create a con,
you know you can't make a slot.
You can't make a girl who's all fucked up in the head.
Well they,
they exist in life.
Okay.
And if you're making fiction,
your fiction doesn't necessarily have to represent anything other than what's in
your head.
What's the wacky story you're trying to get out?
You don't have any obligation to use a certain amount of Asians.
You don't have any obligation to use a certain amount of white people or black
people.
Your obligation is to make something cool up,
make it up,
pull it out of your head.
Well look,
people are worried about entertainment like that.
That's a very,
that one I was religious.
That was our,
well,
Jehovah's Witness Dude,
like every fucking thing I watched like smart,
like a smurfs was off limits for some fucking bullshit reason.
Right.
They wouldn't let you watch the SMURFS.
Yeah.
I mean,
so what it really,
but there's,
I don't know where there's some demonic thing with that and it's all these
fucking,
and then,
uh,
I remember the Simpsons,
somebody came in and gave a talk,
brother Tucker,
his name was,
he was like,
the traveling overseer was his title.
Right.
And he would come and like give talks in the congregate.
I was in meetings like three nights a week.
So he gave this whole fucking talk about all the shit that,
like how Iti was bad because he,
yeah,
because he healed the boy and you're like,
you know,
who do we know is the only person who can heal?
Like I might start believing ut is the real Jesus.
That's the fear.
And then the Simpsons had rebellion against authority with bar and disrespect of
like your elders.
So that's something I could hear the mother's,
well,
I'm not like my kid.
Watch it.
I could hear them chattering after that.
Like that's what this shit is now.
It's like what is,
what's the representation?
It's not propaganda.
So Shit,
just candy.
You know.
So we were talking about this before the podcast to,
do you think that some like overtly upset PC people that what they're doing is
almost like a form of like protecting almost like a form of fighting against
blasphemy that like I remember it goes to my church,
I remember all of them that were like,
oh well you something like every logistical one,
that same behavior.
I believe that 100% I think you're right.
You is the exact same thing.
Yeah.
I don't even listen.
I don't even mind them.
As long as you are trying to get me fired,
I don't it,
you can say whatever you know.
But if you want to criticize,
I'm not against criticism.
Right,
right.
That's fine.
Just do I have to be fired?
Just can we not do that part of it?
Well that,
that,
that is where you find out like exactly what kind of people they are.
Like what exactly are they trying to accomplish?
Are they trying to engage in discourse with a reasonable person?
You're reasonable guy,
you'll have conversations with people,
but that's the thing they want you instantly labeled as an unreasonable person
who's not to be debated.
Well,
you shouldn't even have to bring it up.
You should just know what the right thing is to do.
Remember the Anti Seinfeld Seinfeld,
Chris Rock said the same thing,
right?
Yeah.
But he's allowed to.
That was not an in Seinfeld comes down and it's like,
well,
he's irrelevant and an old man something,
which by the way,
that's like saying someone's fat.
Yeah.
I don't see the difference in that common him.
Right.
Yeah.
I mean it's diffusing his,
his argument and what he's saying is,
you know,
what Jerry Seinfeld was saying was that the colleges are too PC and they'll call
you on everything with his daughter of these days.
They don't even know what the fuck these words mean and what constitutes that.
Right.
And that's exactly right.
That's the,
I don't think that PC ruins comedy.
Like people who are funny are still funny.
It kind of fucks up audiences.
Right?
So we both,
I have the same goals,
one of these PC Beulah.
I think people should be more sensitive to each other and all that shit I do as
well.
But their system is not going to create that.
It's just going to create fucking people that shut down at buzzwords.
Right.
So that's not helping.
Okay.